[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants notre nous jugeons
pas trop ne le dit pas c'est une
surprise ce qu'ils vont être contents
mes deux petits amis ce qu'ils vont être
contents les a gâtés que voulez vous je
les aime je descend vite et retrouver
mon échelle
tels propos
[Musique]
bonsoir
des surprises pour emporter en vacances
mais seulement pour les enfants ça
pas toujours
alors ma petite patronale
voilà pour toi
[Musique]
et voici pour nicolas à merci
mais ce sera quoi ça ça sert à faire de
la plongée sous marine c'est formidable
mais comment fait au viens je vais te le
mans voilà je te dis mon maillot de bain
des mes affaires de mon stack
[Musique]
mon petit bikini
nacre m
j'étais chez
osk l'échec ces sacs ni no 9 comme ça je
suis déguisé et les poissons ne
reconnaîtront pas et tu pourras m à
pékin bien c'est formidable
je peux vous êtes
contentés un chic non merci du collant
un bon gros ne nous y chante ici
nous allons nous coucher mes vins au
formidable
tu vas nous manquer pendant les vacances
tu pourrais pas venir avec nous
j'essaierai de venir vous dire un petit
bout
d'innover créera oui
normes et
la jettent à la
bonne ni les enfants
banimmo ne pas demain
[Musique]
bonne nuit les petits ah voici nounours
patron si vous avez vu leur joie le cher
petit jeu lanfrey encore d'autres
cadeaux et avoue aussi que diriez-vous
d'une jolie cravate verte avec des
rayures nous et il va te ruiner le
nounours on ne garde jamais assez ce
qu'on en a trop c'est vrai mon nounours
allons en doute bonne nuit les enfants
embrasser bien fort tout ce que vous
aimez aller sagement vous coucher du
fait pour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]